I used to we get our hair and makeup
done filming and when we'd be done I was
like what is the hottest restaurant in
Hollywood where can I go where can I be
seen who's there what are they doing oh
my god I need is my car washing yeah and
now I'd say most of it started with
Kanye because he lived a more you know
his his work life is very public but
then like when he was off he was very
private and I was so everything had to
be public for me back then and so I had
to kind of flip it and I now it's like
on my time off I'm like where are the
locations that I could go eat go on
vacation where no one will see us where
it's just all I want is privacy and I
never thought I'd ever be at that point
one can't say that there's a shortage of
talk shows there's a lot of talk shows
and when you want to do a talk show you
know what is it and we thought about
Cavett and Tom Snyder's tomorrow show
and shows where people spent more time
and maybe you give people the choice I
think in conversation it's almost always
a better conversation and the person
you're talking to what they reveal is a
choice I wanted to do a show that way
when we sat down and it wasn't me
memorizing a list of questions prepared
by somebody else in an uber on the way
we're in a taxi on my way to the studio
or to the podcast for that matter we
wanted to do a show where the group of
us producing the show and preparing the
show really really gave it a lot of
thought we watched a lot of clips we sit
down and we really break the person down
as a subject pretty thoroughly the goal
is to make them feel comfortable enough
to get into the long format where you
really let it breathe and it's less
canned because sometimes I think the
segment's people are asked to do are
very heavily produced to get everything
out of it promotionally that they want
to get out and then move off and we want
to try to just let it breathe
I didn't see any of that coming yeah
nothing nothing do you feel the same way
I absolutely I found out when I was
maybe 25 I had walked in on Caitlin my
mom was out of town and I walked in on
Caitlin all dressed up it was Bruce but
dressed up as a woman in the garage at
my mom's house and I ran in packed a bag
so fast shaking and ran out and called
Kourtney and said I have to come spend
the weekend with you and I was
hysterically crying and she just was
like what is it did you know did you
catch Bruce cheating and I was like I
wish I don't know what I just saw I
don't know what you know I I ran out
didn't come home for the weekend and
when you next had the opportunity to
discuss it with him /her
or your mother if you don't mind my
asking what was the dialog about that
well it was Bruce at the time so he had
called me and said one day I'll sit down
and I'll explain this all to you
[Music]